(bright music)
- Woo-hoo!
Take me, gravity!
(water splashes)
- Woo-hoo!
- Yeah!
Ah-ha!
- Woo! (laughs)
- [Enrico] "Luca" is the
story of a young sea monster
who really wants to be a human boy,
and it's about him and
his best friend Alberto
navigating an adventure
into the human world.
- Wow.
Uh-oh.
(boy whimpers)
- Hello, my name is Enrico Casarosa,
and I am the director of
Disney and Pixar's "Luca."
Here we are in a scene
toward the end of act two.
The idea here is that
our two protagonists,
Luca and Alberto,
are starting to really
go their separate way
and starting to have conflict.
Giulia is of course becoming the person
that is in between them.
Luca is learning a lot more from her
about this human world,
Alberto doesn't really know
about the human world that well
so he's starting to feel
more and more jealous.
So when we started writing this scene
we wanted already to kind of
twist a little bit of
a knife into Alberto,
so Luca asks about the train.
This idea of going to school with Giulia
is of course the antithesis
of everything that Alberto wants.
Alberto wants to keep his friend,
so he's very afraid.
And so at the beginning here
it was all about showing how
Alberto is really annoyed
at Luca's interest, at
anything that Giulia does.
Of course this pushes
Alberto to do something
that's very dangerous.
- Then what does he need?
- Me.
We'll just ride it like we
did on the island, together.
Andiamo.
- No!
- This scene is not only mirroring
the first time they do this on the island,
but it's also exactly the same set
where a few scenes later we're gonna have
the climax of the movie,
so it really maps out Luca's change.
He's very scared and he needs Alberto
to lead him down the first time.
Here he's still struggling with it
and Alberto kind of takes
him down the wrong way,
in a dangerous way,
and ultimately in the third act
right in this party
not only will lead down without fear
but it is gonna save Alberto,
and on top of that even be willing to show
his sea monster self.
(uplifting music)
And the really fun part of this crazy ride
was seeing the town.
We knew that the town had to be alive,
the town is a whole character,
and we looked for opportunities
to bring the specifics
of a small Italian town.
The old man playing chess.
Between story artists that come up
with these wonderful gags
and then animators that even add something
to the last minute,
for example the lemons
that end up in their faces.
That's not something that
happens right away on the page
or even in storyboards,
sometimes it really
happens as we start working
with the animators.
And then I love that little alley
they go through at the end
because it just felt like such a portal,
and it's very, very typical.
If you go to Cinque Terre
you're gonna totally feel
like you've been already
if you've watched "Luca"
a couple of times.
(boys screaming)
(water splashes)
(Ercole gasps)
- Porca palette! What was that?
- It was important to set up Ercole
hearing something and activating,
that was the goal of that moment
that we were trying to
figure out how to best do it,
because he couldn't see
them but he had to really,
you had to buy that a
couple of minutes later
he's gonna show up 'cause
he's looking around.
And of course the fun of
Ciccio offering a focaccia.
We joke in the whole movie
nobody eats a focaccia sandwich,
it's like every single
sandwich Ercole is around
gets kicked away,
or he's about to bite
it and he puts it away.
But then of course, yeah,
this dangerous moment is
like, oh, Giulia could see us,
and that's when we're starting
to build Luca's frustration.
Interestingly, this shot
was very, very difficult
because it just felt like Giulia
would have seen them very clearly,
so this shot was full of little cheats
and I think that we had to move Giulia
quite a bit further away
from where she was literally.
- She'll see us, come on.
- [Enrico] This is the
beginning of the scene,
we used to call it splash.
It's really where things
are coming to a head.
- You crashed into the sea.
- [Alberto] It's fine.
- Nothing's fine.
- All of the color palette
was so much fun to really
think deeply about.
We'd do a whole color
script for the whole movie
that maps around emotions
of different scenes.
We were quite careful to not
set that many scenes at sunset
so that this created a
contrast and a sense of drama.
We knew that it would
be supported wonderfully
by very, very saturated
yellows and oranges.
The waves are a wonderful
little thing we did here
because we never did waves like that
anywhere else in the movie.
You will notice almost
every single other scene
has pretty common waves.
Here, we allowed the effects team
to just give us turmoil, you know?
We wanted of course to
feel even the nature
and the weather is feeling the conflict.
- Shut up!
(boys grunt)
- We had a lot of discussions
with our story team
that from day one they've,
this is a kid's movie,
they will have to go
to blows at some point,
they should have a fight.
I love that bite, by the way,
because it was a hint of
comedy in the middle of pathos.
We had long discussions about
whether it should be dramatic
or also a little bit playful and goofy,
and I really wanted those
two things side by side.
(boys grunt)
For a long time,
Alberto wasn't going to
be about to take a swing,
and I remember Pete Docter
had this wonderful suggestion,
he was like, "Tell me the
fight is gonna continue."
And so we kinda made a little
adjustment to this animation,
like he's gonna really punch him,
which I always thought
is such a wonderful note.
(waves whooshing)
This shot is actually mirrored
in our finale, in our goodbye.
There's a very similar shot
where she hugs both of them
at the train station.
I always loved this moment,
the way they look at
each other divided by her
is so wonderful.
In this version of the scene, of course,
Alberto is gonna really
reveal their biggest secret,
so it's really betraying
Luca in many ways.
(Giulia whimpers)
(dramatic music)
- [Giulia] Help!
- I've always been very proud of the fact
that this feels like a sudden choice,
but even more so the choice of Luca
to disown him.
This is Luca denying himself.
- I knew this would happen.
- Sea monster!
(dramatic music)
- Did you hear that? This way!
- And of course we wanted him
to even twist the knife in.
You know, what have I done?
We wanted to feel the
emotion of Luca like, (gasps)
oh my gosh, I caused this,
and I almost got my friend killed.
Interestingly, we didn't
immediately script it that way.
We had scripted it in a way
where Alberto was dragging
Luca in and betraying him
and of course Giulia would
know both of their secrets.
And we realized that that kind of put Luca
very mad at Alberto
but it actually made our protagonist
a little bit non-active.
He was more of a victim.
As soon as we thought of
actually allowing Luca
to do worse than Alberto,
I think it activated this
surprise, first of all,
'cause I think we were
used to the other way,
so I think we didn't see it coming
and I think a lot of people feel this
as a surprising moment.
And allowing him to do the wrong thing.
We even had a few people kind
of doubt that this could work
because it was so callous
of Luca to do this,
but now we could make it up to Alberto.
You would have to try,
act three was really all about
trying to get Alberto back.
- What are you doing?
- I'm okay, I'll be back tomorrow.
I'm gonna fix this!
- It's really strange and
wonderful to watch this scene
after so many months.
What I love the most about
it is that it's surprising,
and that's an important
thing making these movies.
Audiences are so sophisticated
and I hope it does surprise the audiences
when they see this moment of betrayal.
And again, hopefully
then give us the juice
to really want to see Luca succeed
in winning back Alberto in act three.
(gentle music)